[Aplausos]
sua filha da dona eulália seu nome
o torneio dá mas vamos falar em herança
e lançar a obra é importante que a gente
agora sim você já tinha ouvido antes né
herança é algo importante que a gente
ganha pra aproveitar para usufruir bem a
gente tem que agradecer um legado muito
importante que a gente precisa preservar
eu acho que é sobre isso que o pretendo
falar a sugestão dessa conversa com
vocês hoje é sobre isso é algo que foi a
tônica praticamente descobri tarde da
minha vida pessoal e profissional
talvez espiritual também dom pedro 2º
a gente aprendeu na escola ele herdou o
império brasileiro aos seis anos de
idade o pai voltou para portugal dom
pedro 1º e ele ficou aqui com essa
herança um país inteiro
ele não tinha consciência naturalmente
do significado da criança
a minha história guarda alguma
semelhança com a história de dom pedro
1º
eu também não tinha consciência do que
significava aquilo que eu recebi
aos seis anos de idade mas foi também a
minha herança
só que ele recebeu a herança de dom
pedro 1º o seu pai e eu recebi da dona
eulália minha mãe
bem eu sou de uma família muito
tradicional pobre brasileira
vocês conhecem bem o país onde você vive
sou filho de um operário de 60 anos em
dezembro do ano passado
minha família por volta de 1964 composta
do seu joão a dona eulália e mais cinco
filhos
o edson mais velho o isidro a maria o
irineu e a magali
vivemos num bairro de são paulo da
periferia da zona leste à vila diva para
quem não conhece próximo à vila a ema
naqueles idos dos anos 60 era
praticamente uma chácara aquela região
ali a gente vivia como todas as crianças
pobres vive um grande parque de diversão
era a rua ali era pipa ele era peão aí a
mera pelada ali a gente fazia balão ali
a gente brincar na rua
a gente tem uma noção da dificuldade que
a gente dê quando a gente é criança
mas a gente vai ter dificuldade com
infelicidade era feliz
todas as crianças são feliz e não têm
consciência das suas necessidades e
urgências
às vezes não era de sorte eu sabia que
eu era um cara de sorte desde garoto e
não é que eu dei a sorte
um dia eu na rua brincando
encontrei algo fantástico
eu estava andando pela rua e olha que eu
encontro dinheiro dinheiro dinheiro
assim enroladinho nossa meu único desse
tamanho
eu já sabia que se faz com dinheiro aos
seis anos já sabe para que serve o
dinheiro já sabia que dá para comprar
com dinheiro
sabia que podia resolver alguma coisa
pra mim e eu já também tinha noção nessa
idade da falta que o dinheiro faltar a
fazia por uma família pobre
mas eu achei dinheiro
ache dinheiro fiquei muito entusiasmado
contínuo
corri pra casa claro que cheguei
correndo correndo os favoritos
ai mãe achei dinheiro e qual foi a minha
decepção quando a dona eulália view
chega cheio de gachin e de vontade com
solução para algumas coisas e ela me
olha assim do jeito sereno tranquilo e
me diz de quem será o ditado que diz
achado não é roubado
para entender um pouco o contexto sem
querer explorar e emocionalmente
essas circunstâncias filho de operário
já disse cinco filhos vivemos as
dificuldades da época de uma
circunstância familiar
morávamos de favor no barraco nos fundos
de uma outra casa de alvenaria que tinha
em frente
essa casa tinha uma cozinha um talvez
uma sala um pouco estendida em um grande
quarto e aliviamos 17
eu não entendi aquilo como infelicidade
naturalmente não tinha consciência para
isso mas é claro que eu lembro que não
tinha chuveiro
a gente tomava banho uma grande bacia
com água esquentada e tal porque a
economia toda essa era a casa onde a
gente vivia naquele bairro pobre onde a
gente vive o seu joão saía todo dia cedo
pra trabalhar
a gente praticamente não vi o senhor
joão voltava à tarde a gente já também
estava dormindo e talvez os encontros
mesmo com os pais é no fim de semana
como funcionou praticamente a sociedade
quase sempre os filhos ficavam com as
mães dos pais iam trabalhar e os pais
mais antigos em uma guerra para suas
batalhas
mas enfim de quem será a dona eulália me
perguntava e sem mais nem menos
ela me pegou pela mão e já foi para a
rua
naturalmente que eu vou contrariado
acompanhei fazendo figa não vai achar ea
dona andando na areia pouco desce uma
senhora pela rua évora e hoje presente
também em tarouca dônola ela havia um
pouco no zig zag um pouco nervosa
olhando para o chão olhando para um lado
olhando para o outro
a dona eulália ainda sem revelar
pergunta se ela está procurando alguma
coisa então dona perdi o dinheiro do gás
naquela hora eu desanimei despesa figa
porque não funcionou
ela fez assim
meu menino achou que saiu da mão da
minha mãe
assim foi pra mão daquela senhora talvez
eu tenha ouvido graças a deus deus
abençoe
mas faltava ainda um pouco contrariado
e assim voltamos pra casa sem mais nem
menos e lá esse assunto essa história
caiu no esquecimento
o esquecimento de todos e de mim também
o tempo passa a gente se esquece de
pequenas histórias lembranças da
infância mas talvez aos 40 anos vocês
quando a gente pega essa curva da vida
por algum motivo estranho no nosso
cérebro começa a puxar da memória
algumas histórias e aos 40 anos com a
perspectiva do tempo é que de repente é
o de quem será voltou pra minha cabeça
eu em função da família grande e depois
daqueles cinco vieram mais dois numa
mudança enfim eu fui o cara da família
que saiu de casa aos 16 anos para um
empreendimento pessoal eu era
comerciário e aí 12 amigos
filho de um pastor que tinha loja no
interior em botucatu mudança de igreja
ele vendeu aquela pequena loja com os
filhos e pra mim eu quis cumprir aquela
loja sem dinheiro para pagar com
resultados e assim sair da periferia de
são paulo zona leste e fui fazendo
intercâmbio cultural em botucatu para
empreender nessa loja ali eu tive a
felicidade de encontrar meu lugar do
mundo ainda que a nossa loja não tenha
prosperado porque eu já os 17 anos
comecei a escrever um jornal chamado foi
na estrada e aos 18
ingressei na rádio municipalista de
botucatu onde praticamente mudou a minha
vida profissional e também a minha
missão de vida como comunicador
ali também pôde completar o colegial eu
conseguir entrar na faculdade de
comunicação em bauru foi para lá arrumei
uma rádio não tinha dinheiro pra fazer a
matrícula da faculdade é um amigo da
rádio me emprestou devolvido depois de
dois anos conseguiu crédito educativo e
assim conseguir ir para a faculdade
mesmo sem dinheiro depois não prosperar
enfim conseguir ter a confiança de
algumas pessoas para poder realizar
aquilo que eu precisava é naquele
momento fazendo uma curva da história
voltando aqui para os meus 40 anos eu já
em são paulo 40 anos é uma idade
interessante para nós
quarenta anos você se sente realizado
eu já tinha passado por várias emissoras
já tinham big do repertório na
propaganda centenas de trabalhos na
propaganda você se sente um pouco
poderoso
você sente muito realizado você às vezes
se sente até com alguma soberba talvez
do que você pode representar para si
mesmo e não um dia cinza eo passeando
pelo parceiro no ano passando pelo
parque do ibirapuera
não sei por que veio essa história do
que será a minha cabeça novamente e aí
deu um troço mim eu peguei parei num
daqueles portões de entrada do parque do
ibirapuera
parei o carro para visitar minha
infância
e aí eu comecei a fazer um percurso
sobre essa herança que a dona eulália
tinha me transferido aos seis anos de
idade
no ano de 1964 eu estava um cara de
sucesso profissional estava tudo bem com
a minha vida e aí eu comecei a pensar
como é que eu consegui todas as coisas
que eu tinha conseguido não que sejam
coisas grandiosas mas eu me sinto um
cara realizado me sentia muito bem
impulso em outros as coisas que eu
consegui na vida eu devia alguém alguém
fez isso por mim sempre foi de 1 grau de
confiança sempre foi de 1 grau de
honestidade e aí que eu deduzi que a
herança que eu recebi da dona eulália
foi justamente o que deu sustentação
para todas as relações que eu tive na
minha vida seja os amigos que me
indicaram para trabalho normalmente
tinha experiência seja os amigos que me
emprestaram dinheiro sem saber se ia
devolver seja as pessoas que me deram
responsabilidade nas empresas que eu
tive responsabilidades sem saber se eu
tinha capacidade de gerenciamento de
pessoas e equilíbrio para aquilo seja
para tudo aquilo que eu consegui do
ponto de vista pessoal profissional e na
construção das relações fortes que eu
tenho até hoje tudo entende tava dentro
daquele princípio ativo que a dona
eulália assessor naquele dia
naquele dia a dona eulália talvez baixou
o aplicativo na cidade ou de um alto e
zac no software é ética e aquilo foi o
princípio ativo e todas as construções
que eu pude fazer na vida e aí que eu
entendi
gostei o carro daí me recuperei
deixa eu ligar pra dona eulália pego meu
telefone nós já tínhamos celular em 1998
a dona eulália eu tenho que dizer dona
eulália
ela é uma espécie de aguinaldo silva
ela sempre foi muito detalhista ao
contar uma história desde a sua infância
o núcleo central e no paralelo é o
terceiro núcleo ela conta tudo com com
riqueza de detalhes ela se lembra de
tudo você precisa ter paciência quando
você pergunta uma coisa pra ela e ela
vai contar tudo então você não consegue
evitar
ela conta exatamente tudo bem eu liguei
emocionado para dizer obrigado
naquela naquele momento o dólar yuan que
lembra alguma coisa que eu queria
riqueza de detalhes dela dona laura
lembra um dia assim assim
sabe o que ela me respondeu não
como não a dona eulália não lembrar da
glória se lembra de tudo aí eu fiquei
realmente emocionado
chorei e fiquei pensando sobre isso
a dona eulália não sabia aquilo que
estava fazendo comigo
era talvez nem soubesse o que ela estava
fazendo com ela
o algoritmo ali dentro dela também
herdado fazê-la multiplicar esse valor
desse princípio
enfim eu fiquei emocionado chorei e
depois a gente vem nessa fase da vida
com as conclusões
o confúcio quando chegou a 70 anos ele
disse que não precisava mais vigiar os
seus pensamentos qualquer lugar que os
seus pensamentos trafegassem iriam para
um pensamento bom
a dona eulália aos 31 anos de idade com
cinco filhos
não lembro dela ela já tinha esquecido
as suas vaidades
não lembro de um objeto de vaidade da
dona eulália um batom creme cinemas na
área baiana quando era moda dois
vestidos duas saias a dona eulália
precisava vigiar os pensamentos dela e
aí que a gente entende que são as nossas
mães o que são as mulheres na história
das civilizações e aí que a gente
entende que a ética mãe a mãe ética
a ética não está na academia hatch está
nos princípios isso que a gente carrega
talvez mesmo antes da gente ser uma
civilização talvez as fêmeas de todas as
espécies já carregam isso que é da
construção de suas comunidades dos seus
grupos e construção da sociedade e
quando eu falo disso eu não quero falar
da história de mais um garoto pobre que
teve a chance de crescer mas eu quero é
mesmo dedicar a isso as mães ricas
independentemente da posição social que
elas ocupam porque são elas que
constroem esse tecido da sociedade e no
momento do século 21 onde a mulher cada
vez mais têm a sua participação nas
instituições na política e nos governos
a gente espera que cresça mais
certamente pode ter essa utopia de novo
de um mundo desigual
concertado de um mundo que é violento
que possa ser menos violento porque a
palavra colaboração a palavra
solidariedade
elas não são ligadas à nova economia a
tecnologia não essas palavras nem foram
mordidas pela etnologia não tem
histórico essas palavras foram mordidas
no útero
porque era dona eulália ou a sua mãe ou
as tias ou todas as pessoas que
conseguiram pegar dois ovos dois ovos
bater a multiplicar e servir como
mistura para 5 pratos naquela mesa o set
então eu queria depositar a minha
confiança
nesse novo mundo na ética mãe na manhã
fica a gente tenha sempre oportunidade
de visitar os nossos valores os nossos
princípios e multiplicar dom pedro
conseguiu ficar com toda sua herança até
aos 58 anos de idade quando em 1889
fundamos a república e todos os seus
bens foram expropriadas os bens que eu
adquirida do meu salário ficam 100%
comigo e curiosamente ficarão 100 por
cento também com meus seis irmãos e
curiosamente também espero que esse 100%
esteja nos meus quatro filhos os meus
quatro netos dos meus quatro bisnetos
portanto essa não é a história de um
menino pobre que pode crescer mas a
história dedicada às mães ricas e antes
detectada e quer apresentar essa é dona
eulália
aqui ela já está aí né essa dona eulália
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]